jimmy in south carolina what up howard i
was in cincinnati till i was about nine
years old just like jd my bengals fandom
always
stayed locked in and i would like to
hear mr j.d harmeyer address the nation
and tell us how he feels
uh
yeah i definitely uh cried a little bit
uh you did yesterday oh yeah oh yeah i
brought you on here to cry why are you
not crying here i don't understand no
i'm not
[Music]
i'm not like a sober when i cry it's
just you know just tears come out but
did you tape yourself crying if not
you're fired you know that no i didn't
there was no audio of it but i did there
someone does have video of tears coming
down my face they do all right well good
i'm glad you taped it anyway so give me
the prediction on sports go ahead john
now what about uh brady i'm enamored
with this guy because he always wins and
i mean it's remarkable that he's that
age and he's still playing what's gonna
happen give me the prediction first john
hein go ahead
i think in the nfc you've got the rams
who look great last night going to play
tom brady in tampa and i think that the
rams could actually beat tampa bay it
should be a really really good game and
the other people always say that they
think they're going to beat tom brady
and then they don't who's the favorite i
haven't seen the line yet but i'm
guessing the bucks will be a slight
favorite in that game okay all right and
the afc
you've got jd's bangles who are red-hot
they look fantastic great quarterback
joe burrow he's reversing he's reverse
jinxing now this is our reverse jinx
what are you seven years old reversing
what he does yeah he's seven years old
this is what he does
howard i'm just trying to give you the
information that's happening in the game
okay they've got a great offense they're
coming off a win they're the hottest
teams in football right now
they're going to play the number one
seat of tennessee titans at tennessee
will they win or lose i think that the
bengals can win this game all right then
they will play the winner of the game of
the week which is the buffalo bills
going to visit the kansas city chiefs
that's going to be a fantastic game
which i think kansas city is going to
win in a squeaker so that leaves uh
kansas city
hosting the cincinnati bengals the next
week to see who goes to the super bowl
who will win i think the chiefs will
beat the bengals and go back to a third
straight wow
and who will win this time go chiefs
as long as they don't have to pay for it
by the way uh mr freeze has joined our
show
richard christie
hey i had to shave my own head
i missed a few spots you look like a cue
ball now
[Laughter]
richard um you you believe it'll be
kansas city again against tampa bay but
you think kansas city will win john you
think who will win i think the kansas
city chiefs will win the super bowl you
do
wow i actually think it'll be chiefs
packers i think uh
aaron rodgers will beat tom brady this
time in the playoffs hmm
that's because richard hates tom brady
he despises tom brady i mean listen he
did a tour of the series of our studios
the series years ago and he was the
sweetest nicest guy in the world but as
a player i'm tired of him he's
terrorized the chiefs for too long it's
like don't you find that he's had enough
good i find it inspiring
that enough no soon to be 45 year old
man
can could be playing at that level i
mean i don't think it's ever been done
before has it
it's has but it's enough it's like okay
richard will not watch the super bowl if
tom brady is playing in it whether he is
or not he will not watch it because of
his hatred for tom brady if the chiefs
aren't in the super bowl richard you're
not going to watch it no way ghoulies
three ghoulies go to college
we're watching my wife and i already
made plans